[Music]
welcome back to cbs morning some
unlikely voices are highlighting what
they say is a big danger to our forest
and our planet from items that we use
every single day now procter gamble
makes some of the most popular paper
products you see in america now two
descendants of the company's founders
are pushing to change how those products
are made anna warner is here with an
interview that you'll see only on cbs
mornings i'm looking forward to this
because we do use this stuff every
single day good day that's right gail
good to see you too you know these
descendants they have no ownership in
the company but they feel a personal
obligation to go public about this
they're relatives of the founder a
brother and sister speaking out for the
first time to say in this time of
climate change they believe the company
founded by their ancestor is putting
profits over the planet
procter gamble has a long history in
america you yes you will love gentle
ivory soap and it's 29 year old justine
epstein and her 26 year old brother
jules feeny's history too they're proud
sixth generation descendants of james
gamble who began the company with
william proctor we grew up always
knowing
as far back as i can remember that we
were related to the founders of procter
gamble today png is a roughly 350
billion corporation with household
brands including febreze gillette crest
and sherman it's still really a shock in
some ways to realize just how
far-reaching their products really are
that growth has benefited them but more
recently brought concerns about their
family's legacy i started to see procter
gamble products on boycott lists last
summer and
i wanted to know more
for example the nrdc and environmental
group gave p g's popular sherman an f
for sustainability
sweet pillars of softness this is soft
soft yes but some of the wood pulp used
to make it comes from canada's boreal
forest one of the world's remaining
intact forests considered key in the
fight against climate change the
absurdity of cutting down such an
essential ecosystem for a product that
we will use one time and it will go into
our septic systems or into the sewage
to me is really just absurd
that's one reason they say they decided
to speak out for the very first time i
understand the way that corporations
behave i i know that their bottom line
is profit but in this case it's personal
yeah it's easy to eye roll at a big
corporation and say we can't do anything
about it in our case
we looked at each other and we're like
we can
so last october they sent this letter
shown publicly here for the first time
and shared exclusively with cbs news to
png's chief executive officer david
taylor saying while they take pride in
the company's innovations they are
deeply concerned to learn that their
production is coming at a terrible price
to the planet and its inhabitants 88
descendants from both the proctor and
gamble families signed it asking p g to
take full responsibility to address its
impacts on forests communities and the
climate crisis so you wrote this letter
we actually requested in that letter to
me with
the ceo but instead of a meeting with
taylor they say png offered a
presentation is that what you wanted no
to me it felt a little bit
like
a pr solution basically to say we're
going to tell you what we're already
doing because we think it's enough png
officials confirmed no meeting with
taylor was offered but said they've met
with descendants on a range of important
topics including responsible sourcing in
regard to toilet paper png says its wood
pulp sourcing absolutely prohibits
deforestation and estimates less than
one percent of its global wood pulp
sourcing includes intact forest but it's
not just the descendants urging p g to
do better while procter gamble has made
some changes to its forest policies it
has not addressed the fundamental issue
thomas peterson is with green century
equity fund an investment firm that last
year put a resolution in front of p g's
shareholders asking the company to
increase its efforts to eliminate
deforestation for example by using more
recycled materials they are
not changing their plan to continue
sourcing a hundred percent virgin fiber
for their tissue products and that's a
major source of concern for us that they
haven't changed there the resolution
passed with 67 percent of shareholders
approving it that's unprecedented that's
a shareholder rebellion png says it's
focused on developing innovations but
needs to keep using virgin forest fiber
for its toilet paper that not doing so
would hinder its ability to make paper
products significantly impacting its
business but these siblings say they'll
keep pushing for the family business to
change we want to be able to say hey
this is a company that we can be proud
of being descended from what do you
think james gamble would think i would
like to think that he'd be proud of us
i certainly hope that six generations
from now
that our descendants are proud of us
png says it is committed to a public
investment of 20 million dollars over
five years of innovation in non-wood
fibers but these descendants say with
the pace of climate change that's not
enough and it's not happening fast
enough so environmentalists say making
toilet paper out of trees is just an
environmental catastrophe
but procter gamble says they're
committed to responsible sourcing right
what are they doing right so p g will
tell you that they source from
responsibly managed forest areas but
what these descendants are saying is
look taking any trees out of these
intact forests these are the forests
that remain on earth to help keep carbon
in protect against climate change and
they're saying look the climate
emergency is here you know you can't
just say well we're researching we're
doing this you know we're doing the best
we can we're working on it they're like
working on it's not enough time is
literally running out time's running out
i was running i gotta get on it i was
relieved during your piece i checked the
toilet paper that i use at home it's
called plant paper it uses bamboo that's
a new thing bamboo right and innovation
tony you're doing your points want to go
around the table and endorse our various
paper products i love that they're
speaking up though anna what are other
family members saying i was wondering
what you know they had they had these
descendants sign on as you saw like some
90 it's actually 96 descendants who
signed on everybody from grandfathers
all the way down and there's actually a
tradition their dad spoke up about some
png practices i think was back in the
70s wow so you know there's you know
they're not all going public but these
two decided to take this step which is a
big step forward for that yeah anna
thank you very much